جبهه ريمان في مقاطعه لطالما شكلت محور
تركيز لدى طرفي الحرب منذ شهور لموقعها
الاستراتيجي تعلن الدفاع الروسيه
استهدافها مواقع للجيش الاوكراني فيما
يعرف بمنطقه حزام الغابات ولماذا نقطه
انطلاق رئيسيه في الشمال في خرسون فيما
يبدو محاوله لمنع تقدم اوكراني تكشف قوات
دينيبرو في الجيش الروسي قصفها بالمدفعيه
والمسيرات مواقع لقوات المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه واحبطها محاوله اوكرانيه لنقل
جنود بقوارب سريعه وفي مقاطعه داخل روسيا
تعلن سلطاتها اصابه شخص جراء محاوله تسادل
ما سمتها مجموعه تقريبيه اوكرانيه لاراضي
المقاطعه بمقابل استراتيجيه ارباك
اوكرانيه واضح شرقا تضرب روسيا غربا في
ليبيفيف القريبه من الحدود البولنديه هجوم
صاروخي شملها وثلاثه عشره منطقه اخرى قالت
قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان قوت
اسقطت عددا كبيرا من الصواريخ وبمقاطعه
فولين دوما في غرب اوكرانيا قصف روسي
استهدف مصنعا لقطع غيار السيارات وفق رئيس
بلديه مدينه لوتسك التابعه للمقاطعه
بالمجمل تتحدث الدفاع الروسيه عن تنفيذ
هجمات مركزه باسلحه بعيده المدى وعاليه
الدقه من الجو والبحر تقول انها استهدفت
مؤسسات رئيسيه في الصناعه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه وتشير تحديدا الى اصابه مركز
قياده الحرب الالكترونيه وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي للقوات الاوكرانيه فكره
المتحدث باسم قياده القوه الجويه
الاوكرانيه اشار الى توجيه الطائرات
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه صواريخها من نوع 22
الى مدينه كرامه مما صعد اسقاط بعضها كما
كان لافتان اشارته الى ان اطلاق صواريخ
روسيه من بحر قزوين اعقب ذلك معركه
الصواريخ دفعت مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
عن استخدام روسيا صواريخ من نوع 101
ويحتوي الواحد منها على نحو 30 قطعه
مستورده ما يطرح تساؤلات بشان مصادر هذه
القطع بالمقابل تتحدث الدفاع الروسيه عن
اعتراض الصواريخ كروس بعيده المدى
الفرنسيه السنه من طراز
اورجان وعن اسقاط 25 مسيره تلك تطورات
الشرق والغرب ولا تبتعد الجبهه الجنوبيه
عما يحدث هناك باعلان القياده العسكريه في
اوديسا اسقاط خمسه عشره مسيره وثمانيه
صواريخ متهمه موسكو بالسعي لتدمير البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ الاوكرانيه وذاك عنوان
معركه اخرى على ضفاف البحر الاسود